c'est pas pour toi le péché le plus gros
lot on apprécie aussi le cliché de dire
que le rugbymen c'est un gros bourrin
qui a 2 cuill qui pensent qu'à se battre
ça c'est je passe le plus beau cliché ce
qu'on a on ailleurs la l'espèce a évolué
depuis et des arrières sadique
[Musique]
il ya des rugbyman qui sont nés ailleurs
que dans le sud ouest
moi c'est pas les meilleurs en général
mais il y en a ou b patrick sébastien
condé que dans les serres du tour de
france non là on a pas mal évolué sous -
et sur free from desire je sais pas si
c'est vous qu'on fait ça serait un
cliché qu'on est sublime des chansons
paillardes
ben ouais ça va avec le tout le cliché
terroir une bille clocher du sud ouest
les mecs c'est juste des rustres qui
parle avec l'accent du sud et qui chante
et qui boivent à la fin des matches on
est toujours dans le gros cliché du
rugbyman de base mais souvent bien
évolué souvent que l'essentiel au rugby
c'est la troisième mi temps
ouais ça ça reste un peu toujours
l'image du rugby amateur on mange on
boit du vin rouge avant le match on
finit le match
une clope derrière le vestiaire et en
par la troisième mi temps mais ça a
quand même pas mal évolué on est on est
très loin de tout ça maintenant on est
plus avec des jus de récup et les
chaussettes votre cotation après match m
c'est intéressant parce que c'est vrai
ça montre que les gens qui ne
s'intéressent pas au rugby ou encore en
tête ce répit semi-amateurs non c'est ça
parce qu'il ya des fois y'a des gens qui
ont demandé ce que je fais quand je dis
que j'ai fini mes études me dit tu fais
quoi comme métier maintenant j'ai en
effet déjà je sais pas de métier c'est
de jouer au rugby
même si ça fait des années que c'est
passé pro que tous les matchs sentez
visé
maintenant il ya des milliers à des gens
qui n'ont pas encore fait le sujet à
l'image des rugbymen qui livrent des
coûts s'est vu que c'est pénible ces
images où c'est aussi une réalité
non ça reste une image parce que
aujourd'hui avec l'enchaînement des
matches les semaines lui vu l'intensité
des entraînements à lasser très
compliqué de faire des soirées on peut
pas faire descendre tout le week-end
mais bien sûr qu'elle a auprès des
grandes victoires des titres c'est
important de passer du temps ensemble et
de passer des bons moments mais je pense
que c'est aussi vrai dans les autres
sports que dans une vidéo souvent qu'une
vraie humaines sont tous des armoires à
glace c'est vrai on fait moi je fais 75
je suis patient et je rentre trop dans
la catégorie d'armoire à glace et
puisqu'il vient aussi aujourd'hui c'est
que ya pas mal de joueurs avec des
petits gabarits qui qui qui performent
au niveau international et cela donne de
l'espoir aussi à beaucoup de deux jeunes
parce que quand on est petit ou fin à
l'adolescence on est si on peut être
vite mis de côté mais moi au début on me
dit que j'étais trop petit j'étais pas
forcément a pris dans les sélections à
cause de ça donc ça prouve aussi que
c'est fait pour te ment des clichés les
gens qui ne s'intéressent pas
nécessairement on sur le rugby c'est de
voir qu'ils ressemblent tous à des
boxeurs après 80 minutes
ça dépend quelle force déjà il y en a
forcément assez selon les numéros que
nadal doit on fait pas le même métier ça
c'est sûr et il ya certains numéros où
les mecs ils ont le maillot qui est qui
est propre à la fin du match nice ans
ils sont pas abîmés et d'autres un peu
plus il ya les soldats qui sont à la bim
il y en a il y en a d'autres mais
certains sont restés sports de combat et
d'engagement mais on est loin de la boxe
encore dernière question relou c'est
tous les rugbymen ont les oreillons
choux fleurs ça vachement sort pas mal
non plus ça dépend des postes il y en a
certains qui qui à la fin de leur
carrière ont besoin d'un petit coup de
chirurgie esthétique mais c'est vrai que
quand on voit les figures on peut du
rugby on pense de suite mais qu'avec les
arcades abîmée
les oreilles en chou mais encore une
fois on est dans l'appli chi
heureusement qu'on n'est pas tous comme
ça